so Rosen here we are number one number
one number one you know my heart listen
are you surprised that you were the
first one out no I'm not surprised
actually I'm not surprised because I
knew the house would try to get rid of
somebody with that was easy to get rid
of mmm not good at coms horrible at cops
not just so get rid of her and then form
the alliances so I think it was a easy
pick yeah Johnny's reasoning was kind of
like cuz he he thought that you you know
talk bad about it what do you buy it do
you guys really came by I absolutely not
he said I was cheering for Paris but you
know what I'm a mother just the way I
like Johnny I like Paris - I don't have
ghosts
so she reminded me of my little girl if
I ever had fun I'm so petite when I
looked at her she was giving up I said
no Paris keep going look up and it did
it yeah it just made me so happy that I
could motivate somebody to do that and I
knew when I looked at Johnny he was firm
he was going to win the the comp right I
just wanted that little go to have that
hope and the spirit that she could do it
that was all I had I had nothing against
Johnny I love him still mm-hmm no are
you surprised at Hamza was kind of like
petitioning to keep you on board
Hamza be connected the first day itself
and he told me it was he that you want
to Alliance I said yes you take care of
my back I take care of your back and I
liked it because it's such a good boy
and he did work hard yeah he really
worked hard but it's not possible for
the entire house to they were all
anonymous you know they wanted me out
yeah I think Alejandro will do good I
mean I have no grudges against anybody
yes I do have grudges against Andrew if
we have not put me in hell right I would
not be here it was not looking good on
him that he put all you guys down there
right I know he said that we were the
stronger players did we look strong did
I look strong did I play strong we
surprised with your own strength in that
challenge I was very surprised I knew I
was going to fall first everybody else
news and even Canada knew that I was
going to fall but I didn't I held on
I don't know phone way that courage game
I said I'm not going to be the first
person to fall down
and I was not I was grateful for that
then I said no my boys are watching I
don't want to fall yeah and I kept
saying you're not going to you could
need to try harder and harder and harder
and I was screaming on top of my voice I
don't know for what reason but I did it
second person falls now in my height I
go okay if I fall the third one I am
safe yeah but I wanted to check my my
endurance a little more so I said let's
go on a little further more so I kept
saying in my head I'd go keep holding
keep holding keep holding but my hands
didn't listen to what I was saying and I
was down now you know traditionally the
older players are voted off earlier what
do you think that says about like the
culture of the house or the culture of
the show even the people watching well
that's a wrong thing to say right age
has nothing to do with the Big Brother
yeah or any other game you name it I
mean I'm a great fan of Survivor I
wouldn't mind going back to survivor age
has nothing to do it's all up in your
mind you really have to play if you're
willing enough to play you can't late if
I was not in hell I think I would have
survived more
yeah well I mean you're only in there a
few days who did you find that you
connected with really early on my baby
honza yeah yes I did connect to hamster
a lot he's really really a genuine
person and I love Jesse too he's a good
boy and really oh my god all you nibble
on does he is great he's such a good
person at heart yeah but when you go
into Big Brother you don't expect to
find people like this because we we are
in our own different world and to get
everybody from Canada together into one
room and connect with them that was a
beautiful experience are you surprised
that you had those positive experiences
earlier on look what surprised you the
most about going in there my own
strength surprised me because I didn't
know I had that strength to survive even
that one week living on slop I don't
know how I can I'm a very foodie person
I love my breakfast my lunch and dinner
I couldn't eat I even
looked when I was on Slough yeah but I
know know that strengthened me just came
in yeah I wanted to test myself that's
why I went to Big Brother
and I think I did a good job listen I
think they're gonna miss out on having
you around the house didn't miss out on
your cooking for sure
so write about that yeah you're so right
you guys are going to suffer now who
would you love to see move on and really
do well according to me I think Erica is
going to really do well hmm she has the
good social game going on she's under
the grader right now she is a strong
girl and I'm pretty sure she is gonna
win nice any final words for for the
fans for the people in Canada obviously
you're gonna be watching and rooting
people on and seeing how they do right
Canada big brother is not to play a safe
game it is to stir up the ball make them
go crazy that's what we want to see
right playing safe doesn't help anybody
so I hope the two people who went there
just make them go crazy so I can have
fun watching them well before we go you
said this was a you know personal
challenge for you you've overcome a lot
in your life and you wanted to do this -
you had the full support of your family
your husband your kids was it all worth
it it was worth it I've gone through
cancer and this was a different
experience than cancer but this was I
don't I can't even explain here this is
very very different this was for me to
say you know I am getting out of my
comfort zone there was that thing
telling me not to do it
but I had to fight within myself to say
no I am going to fight him so that was a
challenge for me and I think everybody
can do it
yes well listen one of the nice things
about this for me is that now I don't
have to wait so long to come over for
dinner absolutely anytime butter chicken
absolutely yeah